[Music]
good evening
it's always good to see how many quantum
computing nerds we have in san francisco
give yourself a round of applause nice
as uh some of you know i hope um we have
a a unique event coming up uh in october
on october 4th we're doing our very
first
member summit which is actually part of
our kind of 20th anniversary
year events and we are most of the
programming for that summit is going to
be
programmed not by us but by you
our members and so we're taking in
applications now for an ignite talk
series and then there's going to be an
unconference part of it where you can
just sign up for certain hours and and
do tables we will have some uh
presentations from long now board and
staff as well uh but the most of the
programming is going to be by you and so
we've got a bunch of great applications
for the ignite talks so far but do check
your email
we're going to be announcing the
ticketing for the member summit coming
up soon
i think in the next hopefully in the
next week or so
and
there'll be a few things on there you
can
you can submit your
application to give a talk and i'd
really encourage um the
more females to
submit talks we'd really like to get a
good gender balance in our talks for
that and
the
we also have openings for sponsorship of
some of the
coffees and lunches and dinners for that
event so if you or your company are
interested in that there'll be a link to
to do that as well
as some of you may also know we have a
new app uh out so that you can watch uh
all all of the back catalog of these
talks on uh ios devices and apple tv so
feel free it's free app and it's a great
way to get
all of these talks while you sit on your
couch
[Applause]
just in case you have any ultimate
questions or pen ultimate questions or
slightly less than ultimate questions
these cards are there for your views
the ones that make it to the stages i
occasionally say are the ones that are
written very very clearly so they can be
read in the dark
and that are short if you write an essay
or a series of equations which might be
appropriate tonight
they probably won't make it up here
quantum computing is
one of those categories of um
thinking conjecture
kind of like many worlds hypothesis i
think
that um
it's been out there for a while as a
conjecture
but as far as i know
no philosopher has yet decided that it
will cause the extinction of humankind
unlike ais for example
but if you compare and contrast
the potential power of ais and the
potential power of quantum computing
ultimate thoughts do come to mind and
nobody has been thinking them longer and
better than our speaker seth lloyd
thank you very much stewart
you know i have to say stewart is an
iconic person in my life um in 1970 my
parents tossed my brothers and me in a
vw van and drove us from massachusetts
out to bellinis california where we
spent a year and so far as i remember
we spent most of the year uh just
looking at the first whole earth catalog
actually my older brother ben is here in
the audience he can confirm this um
and it it opened up this kind of amazing
picture i mean for those of you around
in 1970 particularly for those of you
around in bolinas in 1970 it was a
different world in that time and it also
seemed like it might be a very different
world in the future
alas a lot of it was more of the same as
it turned out
but uh
but this idea that the world might be
different is a great one um i i do want
to do a little shout out to the long now
foundation to stuart danny hillis the
other people who have made this
wonderful foundation you know they're
back in the 1920s and 30s there was a
movement called futurism
and um uh
futurism was a movement of thinkers who
were thinking we're going to redesign
the future
um
uh in fact they're the marinetti who was
one of the main italian futurists he
wrote a futurist cookbook i i couldn't
help but being reminded of it as i was
past many of the the fine foody places
in san francisco today with strange
dishes he had a dish that was ball
bearings in white paint
um i've eaten things in restaurants that
look like that actually
but futurism is uh you know it it was
unfortunately associated with fascism
actually and i think one of the problems
is that they were trying to redesign
human beings in the image of what they
thought the future ought to be
instead of looking at the way that human
beings are now
and seeing how human beings could be now
in the future
so i think it's a fantastic thing that
you've started a movement not a futurism
but of now ism
not maoism
not taoism
but now ism i think this is a wonderful
thing because the way that we are going
to actually understand the future is by
looking how he lives our lives now and
what things about the way we might live
our lives now may persist in the future
now there's a this is a great way to to
try to think about this is not to look
at you know all the apps and things that
we have right now and see what they're
going to be like in the future you know
we'll have an app for everything uh uh
including we will no longer have to go
to the bathroom you know uh but uh um
but leather looking at things in the in
the past as well
um and i'd like to start a little bit
about talking about the past first of
all i spent a very it was a very
beautiful day here in san francisco i
haven't spent enough time in this
gorgeous city was lovely and i walked
around for five hours instead of
preparing this talk which i should have
been doing
and i turned a corner over by um north
beach and i saw the golden gate
and um
i remembered this poem that when i was
10 in 1970 i remember my father the
first time we went to san francisco he
he said this poem to me it's by a native
son robert frost
and it goes dust always blowing about
the town
except when sea fog laid it down and i
was one of the children told some of
that blowing dust was gold does anybody
know this poem here
no wonder
that's right all the dust um uh all the
all the dust the wind the sky
up into the the like uh sorry now i
don't remember i was only ten right
[Laughter]
like a god in the sunset sky but i was
one of the children told some of that
dust was really gold
such was life in the golden gate dust
gold dusted all we drank and ate
uh but i was one of the children told we
all must eat our peck of gold
it's um it shows you that life is
different right i mean uh it is
different in the now the streets are
paved
uh but you know it's still golden around
here this is a very lovely thing about
here
um and uh you know robert frost was
someone who was speaking about his own
life as a child in um san francisco in
the 1890s and uh many things are still
the same
i think we should also think of the
sameness of lies as well as a difference
so
at the risk of mangling another pawn
here's a much older poem
nelmezzo del camin di nostro avita
trovais peruna cell vascora que la de
rita viras marita
in the middle of our my i'm in the
middle of my life's uh journey i found
myself in a dark wood where the direct
way was lost this is the um
opening uh uh triplet of of dante's
divine comedy the inferno
um
and i bring this up because um uh in in
the late 1200s when dante was writing
this was a time like today
when at least the european world was
being overwhelmed by a new flood of
information
um
and uh this is uh there are a whole
bunch of new books actually ancient
books from the ancient greeks a bunch of
new mathematics was being brought in
from the arab world
and um
all of a sudden the amount of actual
information the amount of text the
amount of science that was available
grew by orders of magnitude
and this just blew people away and the
response was the renaissance there's a
huge flowering of art
of literature
of architecture
people changed fundamentally the way
they thought because they were suddenly
overwhelmed with new types of
information and they had to do something
with it
so um
we are also in such a case in such a
situation we're overwhelmed with
information information of our own
making
so um avogadro's number
is the number of hydrogen atoms and a uh
one gram
of hydrogen gas um it's a large number 6
times 10 to the 23.
it's also roughly equal to the number of
bits of information that's generated by
our human species in one year it's a
very large amount of information
though interestingly it's rather small
compared with the kind of you know the
amount of information required to
describe the atoms and molecules in my
body for instance which is many many
many times avogadro's number
so
but we're now approaching the kinds of
information as amounts of information as
a species
that are are required to describe the
microscopic motions of atoms and
molecules in a gram of hydrogen
it's a lot of information
of course actually unlike the case of
the renaissance most of the information
we're generating is complete junk
all right it's just garbage right
i mean
some weird thing happened and this
happened during our lifetimes i mean i
think it happened kind of around 1995 or
something like that
we went from being um
hunter-gatherers of information you know
before that time it was very hard to
find information i mean i remember when
i first got to mit in 1994 as a
professor i'd go to the depths of the
library and take out all these books and
like look at old journal articles and
try to find new ones and then you know
longer ago people would go on ships
they'd cross the ocean taking months
risking death to spend years studying
with a person who actually knew what was
going on people would do a lot to find
information here you've seen my i see my
picture of hunter gatherers of red of
information you can sell i gave this
this was from a talk i gave at the rome
science festival so hunter-gatherers in
italian are kacha torre
tori
i want you to note that um in you
probably could tell because of my
anatomically correct drawing that i'm
being critically correct here the woman
is spearing a zero the man with his
little beard is gathering berry-like
bits from a tree
no doubt you could tell but you can see
this
this is my idea of a powerpoint
presentation okay
powerpoint is satan okay powerpoint
it's a program made for business people
to convince other business people things
that aren't true
so it's very good for scientists
hey life is too short for bullet points
you know
so people went from being hunter
gatherers of information
to being filter feeders of information
like this ostrich on oyster or this
balena this baleen whale you know our
job now is we're just bombarded by bits
right and left they're coming past us
all the time we've got to somehow filter
out the few useful bits from this
gigantic stream of information that's
blowing by us at all points
i don't think this is better really i
mean it's actually kind of a harder job
i mean luckily there's an app for that
but uh
we don't yet have the dante app or the
jotto app at least so far as i can tell
though now that i've said it i'm sure
somebody's coding it up right now in the
audience
so um this is kind of a sad thing
um
so uh uh
of course luckily we actually have
computers to help us because not only
computers helping generate these vast
quantities of information they also
provide us with means for kind of
filtering through it for finding
patterns in the information for
notifying us when you know something is
very important for us to do like when
google spies on me so they can sell me
stuff that i don't need um they're using
these all these machine learning
algorithms to comb through my entire
life history which they possess to sell
me things that i forgot i even wanted um
this is progress you know i mean
right i mean you know it's like cell
phones right you know cell phones it
used to be that you had the landline
right and you dial it up and you pick it
up and the person on the other side pick
it up you'd have a crystal clear
connection hello hello how are you right
now if like you have a cell phone like
for instance with my daughters who are
teenagers they have a cell phone a
smartphone so i have to i have to text
them to let them know that i'm going to
call them and then
i text them and then i call them and
they might pick up or they might not if
i don't text them they won't pick up so
then they pick up and then it's like
hello
you're breaking up i'm sorry it's much
big improvement it's so much more
efficient these days
life is just better
okay
sorry that that's i i didn't mean to go
on too much of a rant about information
but i think you know one should also be
i i get like being skeptical of the
futurists with their fascist tendencies
i think one should be skeptical of the
notion that you know information and
machine learning and having vast
quantities of information is going to
solve our problems i believe it's going
to create a lot of problems too already
has
which brings me to the topic that stuart
actually asked me to talk about
[Laughter]
instead of going on a rant about apps
and applaud
which is quantum computing
um
so
quantum computers
are devices that store
bits of information
on uh on individual atoms molecules
quanta and what i'm going to do right
now over the next 20 minutes or so is
i'm going to explain to you how these
work
actually
i don't quite understand how they work
because quantum mechanics is
intrinsically weird strange
counterintuitive
uh
uh i once went to a james brown concert
okay now how many people know who james
brown is here okay thank god like
don't know robert frost or dante but
james brown yes okay
so so somebody said said to james and he
finished the song somebody said james
what are you going to play next and
james said i don't know but whatever it
is it's got to be funky
anyway quantum mechanics is kind of the
james brown of physics it's
it's funky
funky this is a technical term it means
strange weird counter-intuitive
so how does this work why is it strange
we're in counter-intuitive so first of
all let's just talk about information so
so what is information
actually this is a tough question
and um i mean information is uh for for
thousands of years the word information
which is a latin word comes from
infomare to to give form to something
information was what you have in
sentences and words and paragraphs in
speech
it's something that's thought to have
meaning
and
then a big breakthrough came in the
beginning of the 20th century around
1920s and 1930s people realize you could
measure information
now
an independent of the meaning that it
has you could measure information of the
unit of information the smallest amount
of information is a bit
which is a distinction just between two
possibilities zero or one yes or no
true or false
and the amount of information is
independent of meaning this this
discovery by the way was made the name
that's most closely associated with it
is that of claude shannon who was at
bell labs and subsequently a professor
at mit
um
and shannon actually when he was he
wrote his master's thesis at harvard it
was the most uh best-known master's
thesis in the 20th century because he he
showed in his master's thesis how you
could construct a digital computer using
an electronic circuit
highly influential
[Laughter]
and so um the idea that you can quantify
information and then you can also talk
about how information is processed
independently of the meaning was a big
breakthrough i mean the comcast guy when
he like you know connects a cable to
your house his job is to make sure that
you know you get 20 megabits per second
independently of whether you're watching
pbs or whether you're watching porn
right
that's his job and it doesn't matter
what the meaning of the information is
it's just he's just trying to get that
amount of information down
so often you know the
advances are made when we we decide we
can discard some useless baggage and in
this case the notion that information
has meaning is something we can actually
discard or is at least distinct from
whether we can measure it or not
actually we shouldn't discard it because
of course information having meaning is
what gives meaning to everything
okay
so but here is another point about
information
information is physical
information is physical this is a slogan
of a colleague of mine now deceased
ralph landauer from ibm
and what he meant was it's a slogan so
it's not a theory or something like that
but the idea that information is
physical means well could mean several
things one is that whenever we have
information
it is actually registered by some
physical system
so for instance a in a an electronic
computer
information a bid is registered by a
capacitor capacitor is like a little
bucket for electrons you put a whole
bunch of electrons over here out of the
bucket that's a zero you put a whole
bunch of electrons on the bucket that's
a one
and if you go down to the most
microscopic level of a single electron
transistor you could have a single
electron over here you could call that
zero and a single electron over there
you could call that one
and and that fact you can build
transistors of this form in fact i'm
going to talk a little bit about using
these as a basis for quantum computing
um so so the idea here is that all
information uh is stored on physical
systems
and information processing occurs when
the the form of that information changes
so for instance if the electron moves
from over here to over there
then the bit flips it goes from zero to
one
um there's another
meaning to this phrase information is
physical and i'll talk about this bit
more at the end of the talk and that is
actually that all physical systems
store information
so you know an electron's got to be
somewhere
so we'll see there's some caveats to
that some quantum caveats maybe quaviots
we should call them
hey there's there's two ways to make
things quantum right you can you can
like you can take a letter and you can
change it into q like you can quantize
google making it krugel right
well the other way to do it is you like
put funny little brackets around and the
funny little bracket says the thing is
quantum mechanical these are called
dirac brackets that so the google with
the funny brackets is actually the the
logo of google's quantum artificial
intelligence group and i'll be telling
you about a little bit later about some
of the group the work that i do with
them yeah so so q or brackets first what
i call first quantization second one is
second quantization
sorry that's a joke only for physicists
excuse me
okay
let's go to the quantum version of this
so in quantum mechanics indeed you can
have electron here an electron there
quantum mechanics is a branch of physics
that describes how things like electrons
behave it's the branch of physics that
describes how things that behave at
their smallest and most fundamental
level it also describes how the universe
as a whole behaves and how things behave
at their largest and most fundamental
level at any rate it's the most
fundamental level
as we know quantum mechanics is kind of
weird so in quantum mechanics you have
an electron which is a particle electron
over here
we could call that a zero electron over
there you know we could call that a one
but uh uh
in in quantum mechanics there's this
thing
called wave particle duality i call it a
thing because i don't know what else to
call it it's like a principle a slogan
it's a saying
and what it means is that things like
electrons which are particles have waves
associated with them
so you know electron over here there's a
wave associated with the electron being
over here electron over there there's a
wave associated with the electron being
over there and the wave kind of has
something to do with the probability of
finding the electron in this particular
place by the way its wave particle
duality also means that things like
light like light which one normally
thinks of classically as being waves
electromagnetic waves that these are
also made out of particles so a particle
of light is called a photon and the way
this would manifest itself is that our
eyes are extremely sensitive photo
detectors that can actually respond to
individual particles of light so if we
turn down the light in this room things
will get dimmer and dimmer and dimmer
and dimmer and dimmer and at a certain
point then
rather than just dimming out to nothing
our eyes would be responding to
individual photons so we would see
flashes of light individual flashes of
light
actually we don't see them because
there's circuitry in our eyes that
suppresses individual flashes of light
because you know it would be distracting
to be asleep at night all the time and
you just keep seeping all these flashes
of light and keep you awake
but we can detect individual flashes of
light
waves are made of particles particles
have waves associated with that this is
this wave particle duality is this clear
of course it's not clear
[Laughter]
quantum mechanics is weird niels bohr
said once said anybody who thinks they
can contemplate quantum mechanics
without getting dizzy hasn't properly
understood it
so oh he said it in danish which was
more impressive right so
but uh yeah but but uh it's just
confusing i mean einstein famously never
believed in quantum mechanics you know
and einstein got his nobel prize for
quantum mechanics in fact for the
discovery of the notion of the photon
and i know several living nobel
laureates in quantum mechanics who i
won't name because this is being
recorded um uh who also they got their
nobel prizes in quantum mechanics and
they don't really believe in it
because it's strange and
counter-intuitive
you know if you're einstein you get to
trust your intuition
right
uh i mean if you're me i don't trust my
intuition so i'm fine with quantum
mechanics my intuition is wrong usually
but in einstein's case he trusted it
okay
similarly
you're my friends you're not supposed to
be laughing at me
laugh with me please
[Laughter]
yeah so so i mean it's counterintuitive
for everybody and it's counterintuitive
for the following reason
so
it gets really worse here so we have
these two waves all right
i have a wave over here
wave over there now in quantum mechanics
the waves just like waves out in the
ocean here when you're waiting out there
to go surfing the waves add up so if i
have two waves that come in they can
interfere with each other so two waves
that come in like this they'll add up in
the middle like that
but these quantum waves can also add up
so if it's okay to have a wave over here
electron over there here
wave over there electron over there then
it's totally okay to have a wave that's
here and there at the same time
and this is a wave that in some weird
funky quantum mechanical sense that
nobody actually intuits
the electron is both here and there
simultaneously
okay
that is not something we're used
accustomed to you know particles were
not accustomed to seeing them in two
places at once unless maybe it's a
soccer ball with lionel messi but um but
uh
that's an illusion and here the electron
actually is in two places at once this
has no correspondence and real in our
own intuitive macroscopic lives um in
fact um this is our inability to intuit
quantum mechanics comes at a very early
age when when i was um when my uh my
daughters were were very little when
they were infants
my friend liz spelke who ran the mit
infant cognition lab asked if they could
participate in some experiments so like
a good mit exp professor i said yes of
course please take my daughter
experiment on them
well they're very interesting
experiments because um infants infans in
latin means can't talk no talking right
um in and fonts no talking and uh so
they can't tell you what they believe or
think
but anybody who's ever had children
knows that they pop out of the womb
already able to respond to all kinds of
stimuli and also able to express a lot
they can express unpleasantness they can
express sadness they can cry but they
can also express surprise
and um so you can tell when a baby is
surprised from the time that they're
just a few days old so in these these
experiments what they would do
is that they would have a stage these
were experiments with what's called
object permanence they would have a
stage and that had a curtain and you'd
put an object like a toy on the stage
you draw the curtain
and then the curtain would open again
and the object would be gone
okay
so
when kids are younger than three months
old
this is not surprising to them it's like
they're just like okay you know curtain
closes torrey is there curtain opens
tori is not there they're like well you
know i guess i haven't been here for
that long you know i guess this is the
way things are
going to be like this from now on
but after after three months you know
and this is i've seen in my own children
who are being experimented on after
three months uh you know toy there
curtain closes tori gone courtney opens
you know tour's not there the kids like
hey
they expressed surprise
and actually i guarantee that anybody
who here has ever played the game
peek-a-boo with a small child
okay yeah see a bunch of see a bunch of
people played peek-a-boo
you don't actually know this do you
actually know have know this to be the
case because if you try to play
peek-a-boo with a kid who's younger than
three months old
you go like this right it's like you
cover up your face
and they're like ah
daddy left the room
and then you opened up peek-a-boo
oh he's back
it's no fun at all right
so but after three months and of course
in like true mit professor form i also
got my daughter to demonstrate this to a
crowd of people about this size once
but i shouldn't be admitting this on
camera
[Laughter]
so so you know you cover up your face
and the child's looking at you and she's
looking at you and she's looking and
she's looking at you and you go
peek-a-boo and she laughs she laughs not
because she thought you weren't there
because she knew you were there all
along and when you go peek-a-boo
you're confirming what she knew and
everybody likes to have what they know
confirmed again and again independent
independent of your political party
i am not going to go down that road
quantum mechanics there were weirder
things even than quantum mechanics let's
just put it that way
no i better stop
yeah so your intuition in quantum
mechanics if you're not looking at
something you're not allowed to lo know
that it's not there so for instance in
this case of this electron that's here
and there at the same time if you were
to look at it it would either show up
here or it would show up there
but you're not allowed to use your
classical intuition to say oh it's
either here or it's or it's there
by the time that you've established
object permanence your intuition for
quantum mechanics is just destroyed
including einsteins sorry einstein
that's just the way it is i mean
einstein you know he was against quantum
mechanics his whole life wasted 20 years
at the end of his life trying to make a
classical theory he should have just
sucked it up
anyway yeah so
are there any questions
is this clear it shouldn't be clear
it's just strange but this is the basis
for quantum computing because you know
on a classical computer electron over
over here zero electron over there one
electron cannot be here and there at the
same time it can either be here or there
quantum computer electron can be here
and there simultaneously so you can have
bits that are simultaneously zero and
one and that's just the way it is suck
it up
so for the last 25 years i've been
working with people to build these kinds
of quantum computers and to see what
they can do
so let me now move on and don't worry
the the the quiz at the end of the class
will be multiple choice
okay
so let's see what this means for
computation
so here's here is a clap my picture of a
classical computer and i'm the
generation where you know the first
computer i programmed was a pdp 8 where
you had to like key in things
individually on the on the keyboard at
an intel 444 processor at 8-bit 32 8-bit
32k 8-bit words
and you had to feed it in paper tape
actually you had to like feed in bits
words to teach it how to read the paper
tape reader and then when it could read
the paper tape reader it could read
instructions to read the teletype and
then you could talk with it didn't have
a terminal or anything like that
so but in a classical computer you feed
in basically tape with the strings of
zero and ones it turns away and
processes it this is like what my vision
of classical computers my youth with
tape drives and things like that
and then having uh performed a set of
logical operations on it using ordinary
boolean logic and or not operations copy
operations
then it spits out some answer which is a
function of the input
and classical computers doing these
logical operations are tremendously
powerful uh george boole who came up
with the notion of doing logic using
zeros and ones the distinction between
bits back in the 1840s um he he wrote
this he wrote this book about using this
boolean logic he found it was incredibly
powerful being able to do basically all
the things that computers can do right
and he called modestly called this
entitled this book the laws of thought
[Laughter]
hey
[Laughter]
why not
all right
so what's the difference between a
classical computer and a cloning
computer so in a quantum computer the
bits that you're feeding in
these bits are look very spooky they're
like you know do you know this there's
this paradox about schrodinger's cat
which is both alive and dead at the same
time so it's got a wave corresponding to
a live a wave corresponding to dead
somehow that i'm looking at these bits
like like a bunch of like malevolent
schrodinger's cats who are being fed
into this box
anyway these are supposed to signify
that these bits are 0 and 1 at the same
time and that means that the inputs are
in all possible values all possible
inputs are being fed into this computer
and this quantum computer because it's
doing everything in so-called quantum
parallel it actually processes them and
it treats each possible bit values and
instruction and calculates all possible
values all possible computations can
come out
so um this is called quantum parallelism
quantum parallelism basically means
because a qubit quantum bit can be taken
on two values at once then a quantum
computer can do two things at once so
for instance if the zero says add two
plus two and one says add three plus one
and i put in a qubit a quantum bit that
is zero and one at the same time then my
quantum computer is adding two plus two
and adding three plus one at the same
time
and this gives quantum computers a
actually very large power advantage
over classical computers at least in
principle
it's not as large as one might think
because actually the thing is if you
were just to look at the output
just you know you say you say oh just
calculate all possible ways of factoring
this big number and you look at the
output you just get some random that
want the output that corresponds to some
random input and that's not so useful
but if you're sneaky about it you can
make quantum computers do a large number
of different things some of them which
are potentially useful or um disruptive
the the difference is by the way this
there's a metaphor about this and
and um i remember talking with kevin
kelly who was sitting in the front row
about this when i was writing a
scientific american article about
quantum computing back in 1995 or
something like that
a very useful metaphor like this is up
to understand this is that a classical
computer just goes through a sequence of
states one sequence of states
it's kind of like somebody singing plain
songs
but a quantum computer is like a
symphony there are many many different
waves going on at once
this is my my feeble mutation by the way
up here as at uh beethoven's fifth
symphony
sorry i need someone to sing along with
me
in order to get the full symphonic
effect
but the the quantum computer is actually
doing many many lines simultaneously
and the result of the computation comes
from the interference of these lines if
you listen to a chord it has a quality
of sound which is very different from
just thinking about the individual tones
in the chord one by one so the secret in
quantum computation to use this
symphonic effect of adding up all these
waves that correspond to these different
computations in a way that reveals the
answer to your problem
that's about as close as i can come with
a metaphor and we're not going to get
close to the metaphors because quantum
mechanics is weird the only way to
understand it is actually there's a
quote from richard feynman that says i'm
sorry to have to tell you this but if
you actually want to understand
something about the laws of nature and
in the more than shallow fashion you
have to learn some math
and in quantum mechanics this is
particularly true because we understand
the math of quantum mechanics well
you can develop an intuition for the
math about quantum mechanics and you bet
that's all you've got because you don't
have an intuition for actually going on
so sorry about that that's just the way
it is
so
let's see what quantum computers could
do
all right
so quantum parallelism this ability to
do many things at once there are several
quite hard and important problems
that quantum computers can actually
perform and they can solve these
problems much much much more efficiently
than classical computers
so
perhaps the best known of these is
what's called factoring this was a
algorithm algorithm due to my colleague
peter shaw from mit
um
factoring lies at the basis of public
key cryptography and public key
cryptography lies at the basis of buying
junk over the internet
therefore it's very important
but if google is going to spy on me to
try to convince me to buy junk over the
internet then i better well damn well
the other better be able to buy junk
over the internet
so what happens in in public key
cryptography
when i send my credit card to sweet
maria's to buy green coffee beans
because my brother and i both like to
roast green coffee beans from sweet
maria's because they're just so much
better than buying them at other places
um then i send them my credit card
number but before they i do that what
happens is sweet maria send me this
number this public key
the public key i can then i can combine
this public key with my credit card
number and send it back to sweet maria's
in a way that only someone who knows the
private key in this case we hope sweet
maria's only someone who knows a private
key can decode it and the way this works
is you take two large prime numbers each
of about you know 120 digits long
they're very big prime numbers they have
no factors of their own prime numbers
are like you know
three five to
do you know the the the different joke
about the different proofs at all
numbers are prime
i can tell because i'm a professor of
engineering so the mathematician's proof
goes like this it says 2 is prime sorry
3 is prime 5 is prime 7 is prime
therefore by mathematical induction all
odd numbers are prime
okay
all right the physicist proof goes 3 is
prime 5 is prime 7 is prime 9 is not
prime but 11 and 13 are prime so with an
experimental error all our numbers are
prime
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then the engineer's proof goes 3 is
prime 5 is prime 7 is prime 9 is prime
hey all the numbers are prime
i am a professor of engineering i'm
allowed to tell this joke
anyway
the public key is the product of these
two large prime numbers which are the
the secret this is the unknown secret
key these are prime numbers so if you if
you gave somebody this public key this
number r and they could factor it to
find p and q they could break the code
but no simple classical algorithm can do
this 128 bit numbers is considered to be
secure for many decades to come
so you know
according to classical computation then
you're fine
but even a small quantum computer with
on the order of you know 10 000 bits
able to perform about a million
operations
would be able to break this code
by this kind of symphonic effect
a few years ago another kind of this is
now we're kind of like just more
specifically what they can they can or
can't do um uh some of my colleagues and
i uh showed that they could also solve
linear equations if a is a big matrix b
is a big vector we want to find an
unknown vector x you can find that
unknown vector x in time that's
logarithmic in the size of the matrix
which is hard to believe but is
nonetheless true actually we uh i'm not
now descending into geeky jokes but what
the hell this is a good geeky audience
so uh when this came out so basically
the result is you can you can solve an n
by n set of linear a set of linear
equations and n variables and time log n
um and uh uh afterwards there's a slash
stop thread got started on this and by
the way in my line of work having a
slash dot thread is like one of the most
amazing things that can happen to you it
only happens every now and then that
that i think there were a bunch of
disgruntled systems energy universe who
were doing slash dot threads by the way
but you know somebody down the line says
but hold it you try to solve an equation
in n variables you do that in log n you
can't even read out the answer in time
log n and the next person said you idiot
if you read more than log n of the paper
you'd know how they did it
so
so
you guys are you guys you guys are good
geeky crowd i'm going to i'm going to
amp up the geekitude here
[Laughter]
this is good yeah this is good i'm
feeling i'm i better not get too loose
here okay
could be dangerous i might talking about
politics and quantum computing
the last thing which is known um about
or there are many things that are known
but the last major um application of
quantum computers
is to stimulate other quantum systems um
this is an idea that was proposed by
richard feynman back in the 1980s he
said you know simulating quantum systems
like doing quantum field theory this is
a picture of a feynman diagram it's like
a a snapshot of the kind of events that
go on in the large hadron collider where
in this case like uh two electrons come
in make a photon make a virtual electron
photon pair make another photon make
another couple of electrons that's the
kind of thing this is supposed to mean
and these things are famously hard to
tease out on classical computers it's
really actually the same reason why uh
quantum mechanics is counter-intuitive
to human beings we think of things as
being in one place at a time of doing
one thing at what time quantum systems
are doing oodles of things at once and
this means that not only are quantum
dynamics counter-intuitive for human
beings they're counter-intuitive for
classical computers they're hard for
classical computers to stimulate but a
quantum computer because it's already
being quantum mechanical it can simulate
these systems very nicely
and around well more than 20 years ago
now i showed how you could actually do
these kinds of simulations of quantum
systems and we actually did simple
simulations on simple quantum computers
this is a very useful kind of thing to
do if you're a geeky scientist who wants
to find out what quantum systems are
doing um again there's a limited set of
things that quantum systems can the
quantum computers can do but many of
these are very general like the solving
linear equations
um uh the idea here is that basically
solving linear equations you can recast
it as a kind of a wave-like problem and
it's when you can recast something as a
wave-like problem then quantum computers
because they're all about waves they're
all over waves they know from waves then
they can often do it much much much much
faster than a classical computer and
peter shore's fundamental insight about
factoring was that factoring could be
recasted as one of these wave-like
problems and then a quantum computer
could actually find these factors
not all problems can be solved like like
this but there's some important and
useful or in the case of factoring
disruptive problems that can be solved
like this actually i was uh
now at the risk of telling more
anecdotes what the heck so at the um in
1995 i was at the first government
meeting at darpa to discuss funding
quantum computing and this guy named
keith nelson from the nsa
got up
and um he's a very sweet guy keith
nelson actually i i've met many people
in the nsa i must say that that i think
the nsa gets a bad rap i mean snowden
pointed out that they were spying on all
of us
who knew i can't believe that
i can't believe it i'm shocked shocked
i mean really come on look but that's
their job right and i know the people of
the nsa are they're spying on us to try
to protect us from terrorists and i
don't think that they're spying on us to
you know sell us junk over the internet
at least not not yet whereas you know
people like google on amazon and
facebook they're spying on us all the
time to sell us junk over the internet
now which is which is you know which is
more harmful like i guarantee you that
right now out there there's some
terrorists will make a mickey i'm sorry
but they're women terrorists too we
don't want to be sexist about this this
terrorist is looking at his computer
this pop-up window has come up and the
pop-up window says you just bought two
tons of nitrogen-based fertilizer people
who bought two tons of nitrogen-based
fertilizer like these detonators
you know
the nsa is not enabling terrorism it's
all i can say
yeah so keith got up
and he said
he said yeah this is keith got up and he
said i'm authorized to tell you that the
nsa is interested in quantum computing
and then he sat down again and everybody
oh my god oh my god somebody from the
nsa said something
and it caused such a stir that he got up
again and he said
well i'ma believe i'm authorized to tell
you this as well of course the nsa is
interested in quantum computing because
if they were quantum computers then
people could break these codes and we've
been sending out messages using these
codes for decades now and that would
mean a whole bunch of information that's
supposed to be top secret will now be
not secret and because our primary
mission is to protect the secrets of the
country
then we would want actually what we
really really like is that quantum
computers not be possible
but if we if they if they are possible
because of our secondary mission we want
the first one right so
the secondary mission being of course
spying on other people so um
actually by the way this is a great kind
of sponsor to have like uh
like you know they call up they say
how's it going you say oh it's terrible
everything's totally coherent it's not
working at all they say great great
that's wonderful
it only lasted for a few years but it
was they were golden years golden years
[Laughter]
okay
so as i'm suggesting we've been building
simple quantum computers since 1994. uh
1995 or 1996. my my claim one of the
reasons i got tenure at mit is i made
the first proposal for how you build a
quantum computer back in 1993 by
basically taking atoms and zapping them
with light in a very you know if you the
basic notion is if you take some atoms
and you
you zap them with light in the right
fashion then you can get them to compute
i used to say i was once at a wedding of
my cousin and uh who's a cultural
anthropologist and the cultural
anthropologist at the table asked me
what i did one of them was actually
barbara ehrenreich who's a very famous
anthropologist and and popular writer
and i said oh um we take atoms and we
exploit their natural information
processing ability to make them compute
and they were like oh my god that's so
so politically incorrect
hey i say no society for prevention of
cruelty to adams but no i didn't say
that there so i had to i had to
re-explain what we did
and um
so i said oh well you know we kind of
massage the atoms and we ask them to
compute and
afterwards barbara ehrenreich's
companion who is this elderly
african-american activist from
greensboro he came to me and he said put
his arm around my shoulders seth the
next time you describe what you do i
suggest you say you empower adams to
compete
hey it was a great moment in my life i
went like like like one moment i was an
explorer of atoms a nanosecond later i
was an empowerer of atoms
okay so how do you empower atoms to
compute
so building quantum computers so as i
say we've been doing this on a simple
level
for um the last uh last 20 years or so i
mean we have electron here or there and
we can subject them to electric fields
have them move around these are good
quantum bits another good qubit or
quantum bit is nuclear spin spin up
we call zero spinning like that we call
one and spinning sideways like this zero
and one at the same time
we can have an atom in its ground state
its lowest energy state spherically
symmetric state this is like a hydrogen
atom here we can then excite it to its
first excited state where the electron
is here and there at the same time
that's a good qubit
we could have a photon that's polarized
like this so its electric field is
wiggling like that we call that zero
photon polarized so its electric field
is wiggling vertically we call that one
and photon polarized so if the electric
field is going like this or like that
that's zero and one at the same time
one of the coolest ones of these is um
superconducting circuits these are
actually macroscopic systems that you
can almost see with the naked eye you
have a loop a superconducting loop like
made out of aluminum which is uh if in
this loop at very low temperatures
current will just go around forever like
this you interrupt it with this little x
which is what's called a joseph's
injunction i have scurrilous josephson
stories but i'm running out of time so i
won't tell them uh
and uh so super current going all around
like that forever is a zero super
current going around like that forever
is a one and super current going around
this way and that way simultaneously
which i have no idea how they can do
that but it does that's zero and one at
the same time
and there are lots of more anything goes
basically
and then you can if you got these qubits
then you need to have them interact with
each other and control their
interactions to make them perform logic
operations like and operations or
operations not operations copy
operations which as bool showed are
enough to actually
build up any computation and in fact if
you can just do ordinary logic
operations the kind that appear in any
run-of-the-mill computer classical
computer and you can put your qubits in
the state zero and one at the same time
then that's it that's all you need to be
able to do
you can do this by putting atoms in an
optical lattice these are
little mirrors that confine the
electromagnetic field and allow it to
talk to these atoms here
you can have nuclear spins in a molecule
by the way i hope that you can see that
i i hope everybody's following my
beautiful
realistic pictures of of molecules and
atoms like my my gender-specific and
realistic pictures of hunter-gatherers
there's a molecule it's got nuclear
spins in it like carbon-13s along the
backbone they're all interacting with
each other and if you um massage them
with light in the right way and ask them
to process information then you can
empower them to compute
or you could actually put a bunch of
these superconducting quantum bits in
integrated circuits this is actually a
very promising method because you can
build it's been shown now that you can
build very large scale large scale
degraded circuits with thousands of
quantum bits in them
and then uh you can actually control
them this way and you know though we've
been muddling along from two qubits back
in 1996 to you know a few dozen qubits
right now because of advances in the
technologies of doing this over the next
couple of years we should have you know
55 000 qubits over the next five to 10
years actually 50 qubits we're going to
have in a year or two
so i think the prognosis is good for
actually building larger scale quantum
computers these are still tiny quantum
computers
i mean as stuart was saying there's a
lot of hype though actually may i say
quantum computing is less hyped than
things like you know nuclear fusion and
things like that i mean i had this
constant experience with my colleagues
at mit is it you talk to the professor
this is about something like
photosynthesis because it turns out that
quantum computing and photosynthesis
have a lot in common and photosynthesis
uses funky quantum effects like
coherence and entanglement to attain
high efficiency
anyway you talked to one of my
colleagues the professor you always says
oh this method of photos of um
collecting light from the sun this is
incredible you know within 10 years this
is how we're going to be harvesting all
our energy and then you go talk to the
graduate students and they say
it doesn't work
it never has worked it never will work
so
you must always be skeptical about these
things but in the last few years because
of these breakthroughs of making large
scale for instance in making large-scale
superconducting integrated circuits
we're going to be at the scale in the uh
soon i'm making technological
predictions as a mugs game but i think
it's pretty pretty clear this is what's
going to happen
and in addition to these i don't i'm
running out of time i'll go through most
of this but i'll go through it briefly
in addition to these general purpose
quantum computers the kinds of things
that could do factoring factor large
numbers solve linear equations there are
specialized ones there's a famous
company called d-wave in canada that
makes what's called quantum annealer
that has thousands of quantum bits in it
it's not doing general purpose quantum
computing and there's some controversy
over whether it's able to solve hard
problems but it's definitely being very
quantum mechanical um you can have
hey look
everything is quantum mechanical it's
just some things are more quantum than
others right that's just the way it is
okay
turns out that photosynthesis is very
quantum mechanical so
um integrated optoelectronics you can
take things that that would have a few
years ago would have required optical
tables the size of several football
fields to guide the lasers and the
photons through you can put them on a
chip due to technology switching
technologies from
the telecommunications industry so now
you can have hundreds or thousands of
quantum bits on chip and there's also a
fascinating field of making using funky
quantum effects such as coherence and
this effect called entanglement to make
much more accurate quantum sensors
imagers and detectors
um so i just mentioned these in passing
um what are we going to do with these uh
these small scale quantum computers and
this is i think what what stuart was
asked me to wanted to talk about so
given that we're not
sorry i know it's taking longer getting
distracted not talking about what you
asked me to talk about but
when we have these small-scale quantum
computers say 50 to 500 qubits forget
even about 5 000 quantum bits
which we're going to have soon we won't
be able to factor these large numbers
and strike fear into the heart of
agencies with three letters in their
names assuming that they have hearts
which they don't
but uh
uh we will be able to do something
that's very interesting this is my own
personal take on the most interesting
thing to do with these i mean quantum
simulation by the way simulating quantum
systems that's an extremely important
application
um
it's no secret around here that one of
the most important applications of
computers is machine learning
we were talking about this at the
beginning of this talk about apply using
computers to have have them apply their
computational ability to sort through
vast amounts of data to sift through and
to filter out the most interesting
patterns that they can find
this is a very hard problem which is why
you know places like google and amazon
and facebook are paying high salaries
for people who know about machine
learning it's just hard to do
quantum computers could do much better
than classical computers for a variety
of tasks i mean here's a typical kind of
machine learning task you give them a
you give a whole bunch of samples of
handwriting you say this is a five this
is a five this is a five this is a seven
this is a seven this is a seven this is
a seven now what are these three right
here five or seven right
that's called supervised learning
um uh or with voice recognition you say
uh okay you want to have something that
recognizes people's voice this is
actually a more complex problem because
in fact what happens in your smartphone
which is actually pretty darn good at
voice recognition it's adaptive and it
learns over time from feedback between
what you're trying to say and what it
thinks you're saying what you say you're
saying it learns how you're actually
speaking this is a combination of what's
calling called supervised and
unsupervised learning
these systems have gotten much better a
few years ago mit well in around 1998
mit replaced all their their operators
with a computer system now 1998 i don't
know if you remember voice recognition
sucked
um it was terrible but because some
smart ass
engineering electrical engineering or
computer science professor convinced the
administration for the next five years
you'd have this experience you'd call up
you'd say i'd like to speak with jane
smith and the computerized voice would
say now ringing mary lefkowitz this is
not the right number press nine beep
jane smith now ringing hua zhang
this lasted for years
but now they're good they're good
i mean i thought when back in the 80s
when i was a i was a postdoc at caltech
working with murray gilman i went to go
visit john hopfield who's one of the
founders of machine learning and back at
that point a lot of these algorithms for
machine learning had already been
developed but they computers were too
small the data sets were too small and
they were just crapping out and hopfield
said you know if we had computers that
were a million times more powerful on
data sets that were a billion times
bigger this would work i swear
he said that and now we actually have
computers that are a million times more
powerful your smartphone is a million
times more powerful than a uh you know a
supercomputer of the 1980s and then we
have trillions of times the data more
than trillions of times of data so
they're working now
so the kinds of things that you could
apply quantum computers to that would
actually be much much faster or things
like cluster finding finding clusters of
points together looking at topological
features like here's a bunch of data
it's got a hole in it
right it's kind of weird because it's
actually all holes but we can tell that
it has a hole in it a hole is a
topological feature it's something
that's invariant under distortion so how
do you find that or for that matter
financial prediction you know you know
are we right here in this little
fluctuation or are we right there makes
a big difference
right
in terms of how you're going to invest
your money it turns out because of this
ability of quantum computers to solve
these large sets of linear equations
that they're able actually to do these
kinds of analyses much better than
classical computers and even a small
scale quantum computers with a few
hundred qubits able to do ten thousand
operations could kick serious machine
learning bud
okay
so and and this shows where we are um
this is moore's law this is the only uh
people here has probably seen this so
many times you know back in 1950 we had
vacuum tubes then the size of the uh
components of computers the of the ch of
the transistors have been going down
steadily halving in size basically every
couple of years we're right now here
we're at a few 10 or the 10 15 nanometer
scale
for
uh feature size on on computers at the
same time you know the little quantum
computers we've been building we started
at the atomic scale
empowering atoms to compute
back of that was actually back in the
days when we were exploiting them but
around here we started empowering them
[Laughter]
so
moore's law is not broken down yet but
pieces of it are breaking down the clock
speed of computers has topped out at a
few gigahertz about 10 years ago
otherwise if you try to run them faster
you melt the chip
the component size is getting down
basically we're kind of forced to go and
look at the atomic scale for building
these devices
and i think that we're going to have a
good shot at doing it as i say we've
already been doing it for decades now
the question is now whether we can build
large-scale integrated quantum computers
okay
so uh stuart's looking nervous there so
uh uh oh no he's okay oh you were just
looking at your watch
he's got an important date
okay all right so i want you don't it's
okay if i don't rush it okay good i'll
keep hungry keep on going keep going but
i'll be i'll be done soon
okay
so at any rate so i'm now i haven't
tried to convince you that quantum
computers are going to be the next best
thing since sliced bread in fact even if
everything that i say were to succeed
and i don't know if it's going to
succeed i just given you my opinion
which could easily be wrong see the part
about my intuition earlier on
about what's likely to happen with these
quantum computers over the next few
years you may note that these are
problems that are the problems they're
going to solve
are not the kinds of things that are
completely going to transform what we're
going to do
um
but they could make a big difference in
how we're uh processing information in
ways that are important to us like for
instance in machine learning and the
things that are important to me like
finding out how how quantum systems and
other physical systems behave um in
effect you know quantum computers if you
actually look what drives moore's law
it's not just like oh people are
building transistors small and smaller
there's a whole bunch of moore's law
basically for instrumentation and
control
more precision about making making the
wires better precision on the
lithography electron lithography
being able to actually position the
stages on which the chips are sitting
down to the sub
nanometer scale that's extremely
important all these advances have been
going along that have made more law like
this and these are the same advances in
precision instrumentation and precision
control to make quantum computing
possible
so i think we're in a good space for
quantum computing
um not gonna you know just completely
you wouldn't want to run word on a
quantum computer in fact it would be an
insult to the quantum computer
sorry i shouldn't i already i slagged
off on microsoft earlier today
that's enough i need to go on other
people how about open source no
[Laughter]
quantum open source it's a good idea
actually
anyway yeah i have no more no more quaps
to give you here
uh sorry
quantum maps
so
let's move back let me finish off by
moving back to the larger scale so um
you recognize because now the type space
has changed i'm now back at the big
picture here
so what's going on here
[Laughter]
the uh what's going on and this is
something i basically
discovered by trying to learn how to
build quantum computers when i started
doing this about you know two and a half
decades ago
i said
basically anything can store information
all atoms all molecules store
information and quantum mechanics has
this neat feature that in addition to
having this wave-like nature
it makes the universe digital at bottom
so that you know every elementary
particle its spin register is a bit of
information a quantum bit you know the
polarization of a photon registers a
quantum bit electron here or electron
there that registers a bit of
information these register bits of
information
every elementary particle every atom
every molecule carries around with it
bits of information
actually this has been known for 100 for
150 years because the information
required to describe the motions of
atoms and molecules in a gas is what we
call entropy it's this funny quantity
that basically measures a disorder in a
system but it's information effectively
registered by the atoms and molecules
and actually when these particles move
and interact then these bits flip so
zero particle over here electron over
here moves over here zero goes to one
the bit flips
two particles holding bits of
information on their spins they bonk off
of each other their spins flip
then
they're performing more complicated
logic operations but these bits are
flipping no matter what
so you know when we're building quantum
computers we're not exploiting them to
make them compute we're basically taking
their natural information processing
ability by massaging them in the right
way we're empowering these atoms and
elementary particles to compute they
were already effectively computing we're
just getting them to do a different kind
of computation by asking them very
nicely from the one that they were doing
before i'm protecting myself here
okay
so
the interesting thing about this is you
know you know we are
we're you know i as i started off we're
now in this this stage of sad stage of
human development of our species which
we may not survive
we're we're now you know the stage of
trying to extract meaningful information
from a huge sea of bits these are our
poor hunter-gatherers they've now bought
smartphones and they don't know what the
heck to do
their hunting gathering app is not on
there
where is the barry bush app it is not
there
actually if you look at i mentioned
before about the renaissance but in fact
if you look further back
there's a much much more important
information processing revolution which
is actually the development of life
itself
somehow along the way and we have no
idea how this happened we know much more
about the beginning of the universe than
we know about the origins of life
there was this free energy out there
carrying information and something
somewhere figured out the way to
sequester this energy to make useful
information here are pieces here's a
double-stranded piece of dna here are
these atoms and molecules carrying bits
of information the dna says a set of
instructions for the metabolism of the
cell to process this information it's
about information processing
somewhere along the way
life itself arose and managed to start
extracting meaningful information from
its environment and by meaningful i mean
information that allows it to survive
and reproduce that's about as close as
i'm going to get to meaning here but i
think you'll agree that for your average
cell that's meaningful
maybe you don't actually
yeah
so um uh looking at this long now
you know the now has been lasting for a
long time i hope that for the human
species it lasts for a long time too
but this the now of of processing
information
of extracting meaningful information
from our universal surroundings that's
been going on almost as long as the
universe itself
i mentioned before that photosynthetic
organisms are basically performing a
kind of quantum computation they're
using funky quantum effects to get high
efficiency for energy transport
so we should be encouraged you know
okay we're inundated by this sea of
information right now maybe we're losing
the battle but maybe in the future we'll
win it
and so
indeed human life has become what life
has always been an exercise in machine
learning
classical machine learning
quantum machine learning
it's all about that
and thank you
there you go have a seat thank you
good question that kevin put on the top
is one i wanted to start with damon
asked other biological systems already
taking advantage of quantum computing
which you were just getting into in your
wrap up there
um would you like some water by the way
stewart yes please
um you mentioned photosynthesis
uh
photosynthesis
uh is the inspiration for some
pretty serious engineering attempts
going on to basically try to sort of
manage photosynthesis
better
for uh
energy production from the sun
better than these things on rooftops now
is quantum part of that
potential improved capability
um yeah absolutely um you know
photosynthesis uh works a photon a
particle of light comes in from the sun
it hits a chromophore a molecule like
chlorophyll chromophores greek for
carrying color it just means it responds
to light
and it gets absorbed and it creates
what's called an exciton a particle of
energy it's a bound electron hole pair
it carries the energy of the light and
this exciton hops from chromophore
molecule to chromophore molecule until
it gets to a reaction center where it
can be turned into useful chemical
energy that's kind of how photosynthesis
works but it turns out that this exaton
is basically a quantum particle and
instead of going just one root through
this photosynthetic antenna to get to
the reaction center it takes multiple
routes simultaneously
and the efficiency of motion comes from
the interference between these paths so
it's actually using quantum mechanics in
a very sophisticated way
i mean i found this out in 2007 i picked
up the new york times one morning and
said green sulfur bacteria performing
quantum computation i was like oh that's
the most ridiculous crackpot thing i've
ever heard
and uh at our quantum group meeting we
discussed this we all thought this was
hysterically funny but it was from a
very reputable group and uh the graham
fleming group at berkeley and um you
know femtosecond spectroscopy really
beautiful work and so we went and looked
at it and you know uh my colleague alan
aspregus and i figured out that although
it wasn't performing quantum computation
in the way that the fleming group
thought it was actually doing what i
just described that that it's using this
quantum interference to actually
increase the efficiency of
photosynthesis and more recently with
angela belcher and munji bowen at mit
we've been actually building artificial
i would i would call the man-made system
except they're women and virus-made
systems um to uh do uh to try to emulate
this high efficiency in photosynthesis
so i think it's a it's a real
possibility and this is a great use of
quantum information technology how are
viruses involved in that
um viruses are involved in everything uh
but uh
but uh yeah the uh basically angela
who's a macarthur prize winner at mit
she convinces these viruses she empowers
them to uh grow different kinds of
proteins on their on their skeletons
they're so that they're
you can attach different kinds of
chromophores to them and by attaching
different kinds of chromophores then you
can get them to behave like artificial
photosynthetic things when i first met
her i said i actually said oh we're
doing this we're attaching these
chromophores to viruses i said oh you
know if you could attach a quantum dot
to the end of the virus that would be
great you know quantum dot is just a
little piece of semiconductor material
it's optically active light comes in
exotic hops around it falls into the
quantum dot quantum dot emits light
and then you could figure out you know
you could be harvesting this light you
also have a virus that's shooting light
out of its ass which i think would be a
great thing
i said this to a bbc reporter she said
no so no seth it's like comes out of the
top it's a magic wand
next question
let's move on quickly i'm a biologist
viruses don't have asses
yeah how do you know which end that's a
good question i should have brought that
up
a lot of these things come to efficiency
uh kevin kelly's question is how energy
efficient is quantum computing
um you were sort of suggesting as we got
into this the classical computation is
uh energetically pretty demanding
is this going to be a big step function
in terms of just less energy for a lot
more computation
yeah that's a very interesting question
so actually at the level of sort of
individual spins flipping or electrons
moving from here and there um quantum
computers are extremely energy efficient
in fact there you can you can derive the
minimum amount of energy you need to say
to move an electron from here to there
in a particular time and quantum
computers saturate these physical bounds
um so at the kind of on-chip level the
quantum computers are extremely
efficient however to control them to zap
them with lasers or with microwave
pulses to make them behave in this
fashion that still takes a fair amount
of energy however their on-chip
dissipation in quantum computers is
extremely tiny
um so there are lessons perhaps to be
learned for just classical computation
to minimize on-chip dissipation just for
classical computation
um
okay
i'm going to go through some of the kind
of technical questions here josh effort
asks researchers that oxford recently
achieved quantum logic gates with 99.99
precision how far away are we from
quantum computers breaking contemporary
encryption
um yeah and presumably the nsa is uh
what's the first
as you said and when will they get the
first
well actually yeah so probably a good
sign they're about to get there is if my
colleagues or me start to disappear
[Laughter]
suddenly you can't find me any longer
that might be a sign that they're
getting close
they kill you or you're disappearing i
don't know how this works i don't know
the
mechanism yeah but that's a very good
question so so this is one of the
reasons why why
i'm confident pretty confident that
we're going to have medium scale quantum
computers in the near future so people
have now can make these logic gates with
you know 99.999
efficiency which is more than one needs
to make a large-scale quantum computer
if you can do that many many many
billions of times over um to do actually
uh in quantum computers you actually
have to deal with errors in noise
and if you want to make a quantum
computer that is going to do error
correction and have redundancy you need
to have many fold redundancy like 100
fold redundancy for each bit can you get
many many folds with quantum because
it's so parallel
you can but it's also the thing is
because quantum computers just for the
same reason that they're able to do
these many things at once it's harder to
do error correction like in classical
error correction if you have three-fold
redundancy like like zero zero zero one
one one those are your codes for zero
and one so if one bit gets flipped you
can you know correct one-third of the
errors on errors that are like one-third
of the time that's pretty good error
correction quantum computers you need
many many more quantum bits so i think
it's it's going to be a harder problem
to build a quantum computer that will
factor large numbers where you need
full-blown error correction that's why i
was focusing in this talk on the
near-term more near-term five to ten
year goals for quantum computing which
is doing things like machine quantum
machine learning
okay chrono machine learning
machine learning is already sort of tied
into
forms of artificial intelligence getting
better and better yeah and uh some
people are excited and some people are
worried and some people are both oh yeah
yeah
you're saying that i'm not going to
contradict what you're saying that we
should be worried about quantum
computers
just that um
is
the prospects of pretty
deep ai
uh accelerated by all this
well um yes it is accelerate potentially
accelerated by this but can i just say
this i mean i know stephen hawking is a
really smart guy and elon musk is a
well-known guy but the fact that they
believed that
the fact that i believe we're about to
be taken over by giant neural networks
it's just you know i'm sorry that's just
not going to happen i mean it's like i
mean maybe we should worry about it but
it's not going to happen i mean actually
in fact the when you talk to people in
brain and cognitive sciences
in fact the if we look at what's going
on the brain it turns out what's going
on the brain is much much more
complicated and varied and detailed than
what's going on in these large-scale
neural networks and they're not going to
actually start thinking like human
beings which is maybe a good thing um
give them the political process no sorry
no there was so i don't think one should
be worried about that but i mean you
know this the if you look at the quantum
version be excited about it so what
would what should we be excited about
given all this well so i mean so let's
look at the you know the um
there's this thing called deep learning
i'm sure people heard of deep learning
here i only heard about deep learning a
few years ago um when we started to do
this this quantum machine learning and
at first i was really excited it's like
wow now like
artificial intelligence are going to
tell us deep things like you know truths
about love and life and you know
happiness and then it turned out it was
just deep learning is just like a neural
network with many layers you know
which can recognize handwriting a lot
better
so
and other things as well i mean i don't
mean to it's great it's a wonderful
thing if you look at the stuff i mean
working with the google quantum
artificial intelligence group with hart
mcnevin there who's you know one of the
main feature people in deep learning
they can do remarkable things and doing
the quantum version of this deep quantum
learning which we have to do just
because deep quantum learning sounds so
cool
that's a good reason to do things by the
way
because you can
what does steep mean in that case
actually do you think yeah so deep means
the reason that deep learning succeeds
better than the kind of shallow learning
is if you make a deep neural network
with many many layers
then it connects more symphonic in your
terms it's more yeah so right the
classical version first of all can you
know the shallow ones can't compute the
way out of a paper bag but in a deep
network you can encode any kind of
quantum sorry of classical logic circuit
in it so it can effectively in principle
do anything a computer can do which is a
lot and similarly in a deep you know a
universal deep quantum learner you have
a would have a deep quantum network and
by the way people are building these
devices right now these are one of these
special purpose devices i mentioned with
thousands of qubits then it could
actually do anything a quantum computer
could do so in the same way that quantum
systems can generate patterns that are
weird and strange and funky and
counter-intuitive and we can't generate
them classically then maybe these
quantum computers can also learn
patterns that are strange and funky that
we can't learn classically
so hence here and other people saying
that quantum can help learn about
quantum i mean that was sort of a
finance point back when it can help
learn about quantum maybe could also
help learn about i don't know life love
truth happiness well yeah and beyond 42
the
biology
is fraught uh and has been fraught and
is showing signs of being fraught you
know almost forever so that you know
ecology is not a predictive science it's
an observational science there's no
equations that that hold up
uh the brain is still uh pretty much you
know
you have
cartoon neuronal networks but they are
cartoons compared to what's in here
we have a question in here about
brain and quantum which we'll get to in
a minute
um
the immune system i mean all these
biological systems
defy
analysis because of the levels of
complexity is quantum going to be a
window into
that well um i mean i think there's a
good reason why these systems defy
analysis
well so so um it's actually one of the
reasons why human beings are often
mysterious to each other and why we're
often mysterious to ourselves
so in in
alan turing's original paper about
turing machines which are the
archetypical idea of a digital computer
he was trying to understand what's
called the halting problem sorry the
girdle's incompleteness theorem which is
this this deep piece of logic which is
hard to understand that basically says
when you have the capacity for
self-reference
then you can no longer understand what
you're going to do or predict what
you're going to do so turing proved what
he called the halting problem which is
that he developed these touring machines
there are models for digital computation
he showed that they actually have the
capacity for self-reference so for
instance say
consider the operating system in your
smartphone the operating system is a
computer program
and it goes and looks at all the other
programs all the apps in your smartphone
and it allocates
time and space for these apps to
function
now it itself is also a program in the
computer
these programs have numbers right so you
know this the the operating system is
saying what does program number five
need what was program number 723 need
let's suppose it's its number is 42
right so it says what does program
number 42 need that means it's asking a
question about itself and what turing
effectively showed is that if you can
ask questions about what you yourself
were going to do you won't be able to
predict it
so the operating system the computer
will not because it can ask is capable
of asking the question what will program
number 42 do
a lot of the time it won't be able to
answer it which is why computers crash
and why you know they're also
intrinsically unpredictable
and you know human beings have this
capacity and the iron and also
interestingly the immune system has this
capacity i mean autoimmune diseases come
because the immune system which has this
capacity recognized self versus other
which is in fact what the immune system
is supposed to do
because it has that capacity then
sometimes it must fail to perform this
recognition so i think a lot of this
inscrutability
of biological systems and of human
beings and and computers themselves
comes from the fact that they're
complicated enough to be able to ask the
question you know what am i going to do
and then the answer is heck if i know
you seem to be saying that financial
markets are not of that level of
complexity that they can be predictable
uh in a quantum mode
uh uh no i wish that that was just like
part of a fundraising
hey that's why people do this stuff
right for money right let's be realistic
no i think actually financial markets
are are inscrutable for a rather similar
reason
i mean there are a lot of people trying
to predict them so it's like has this
kind of inward self-looking uh aspect
and any prediction that starts to win is
immediately destroyed because other
people copy it and then
uh michael taff asks what about using
entanglement for instantaneous very
long-distance internet-like
communications can we entangle okay so
we actually didn't talk about
entanglement here so entanglement is a
this funky quantum effect so if you have
a one quantum bit it can be in two
states at once zero zero and one
simultaneously so if you have two
quantum bits they can together be in a
funny quantum state where say they're
you know zero and one
and one and zero at the same time
this is a funny they're in a correlated
state or anti-correlation i see this one
and it's one this one is zero if i see
this one it's zero this one is one
but they're just in one state they're in
zero one and one zero at the same time
this is really hard to understand
and it also gives the illusion
that you can actually communicate very
rapidly so if i have these the suppose
that this you have one of these qubits
and i have one and i go and i measure it
and i find that it's zero then it
appears to our intuition that
instantaneously yours has gone from
being either zero or one or zero and one
at the same time to being just one
all right
so it looks to our classical intuition
as if by doing something over here i've
changed something over there
but the fact is you can't use this funky
effect entanglement to send information
you can only take advantage of existing
correlations so you can't use
entanglement to send information for
instance faster than the speed of light
what's andy what can you use
entanglement for
uh yeah actually uh my colleague charlie
bennett said it's kind of like
entanglement so so things being here and
there once is already counterintuitive
and baffling so entanglement is
something that you use to confuse and
baffle people who don't understand
quantum mechanics so that's right
primary use
[Laughter]
so it looks like a name dab vaganuma
asks can you speak about the chinese
quantum satellite experiment that just
launched
yeah so so a number of uh countries
including the united states china and um
and canada actually who is canada is a
powerhouse in quantum information they'd
be winning gold medals at the olympics
if it were an olympic sport but uh they
chose uh chosen about uh 15 years ago to
really invest a very substantial amount
of money government money the government
but also mike lazaridis the head of
research and motion
donated about 400 million dollars over
the years to
studies of quantum information both at
the perimeter institute in waterloo and
the university of waterloo so canada's
invested a lot of money and they have
also done preliminary
ground to satellite
quantum information experiments
so um uh yeah you know this is actually
um there's something there's a kind of
sadly or unfortunately named feature in
quantum mechanics called quantum
supremacy
um i know this is this is so politically
incorrect i just can't i can't believe
it so the idea but it's an interesting
notion it's this idea that a quantum
mechanical system can generate events
with probabilities that no classical
system could do
um
and then somebody unfortunately called
this quantum supremacy that the quantum
system right right right
yeah i mean of course i mean it could it
could have the advantage like if you
know if trump is elected president then
we could say we need to restore
america's quantum supremacy by investing
in quantum information but
in which case you're cool yeah we're
good right then we're good to go
yeah so it's an interest so these
experiments are very interesting so
they're trying to distribute
entanglement this long distance funky
quantum correlation from ground up to
satellite
so um you know up from ground up to many
miles up in the above the atmosphere
actually the hardest part is going
through the atmosphere because the
atmosphere is the most absorptive part
once you get above like 10 miles
actually it's it's there's almost no
clear sailing from there on right yeah
so i mean basically you take a laser you
send a throat photon through a little
like a funky
nice uh
cool looking
colored crystal and a photon will then
split into two photons each with half
the energy and these two photons are
entangled with each other and then you
can keep one of them around in like a
fiber optic cable and send the other one
up to a satellite okay and you can
establish a tanglement over many many
miles actually people have been doing
this routinely over distances of
hundreds of kilometers already like
between
different canary islands and things like
that so yeah so it's a perfectly doable
thing
once you do it you can use it to do
things like quantum cryptography to
establish secret keys sending them up to
the satellites
can you do
one of the things i noticed with the
institute you're mostly uh
doing in cambridge now is things like
sensing what's what has sensor
capabilities expanded by all this
yeah so actually entanglement the if you
i mean so i guess i i was uh i was i was
kind of saying there are much more
useful uses of entanglement than just
baffling okay your butt spells them out
yeah so so in fact when you take these
states these entangled states of light
um then um and you can use them to do
the following funky thing which is that
um if i want to say detect something
that's out there say there's an object
out there there's not an object out
there so i send one of these photons out
if there's no object it just goes away
forever if there's some object it
bounces back right with some tiny
probability and there's also a bunch of
noise around
then you can ask look at the photons
that are coming back and say are you
entangled with the photon i kept here
and it turns out that if the answer is
yes then it's much more likely to be the
photon you've sent out so you can
enhance the so-called signal-to-noise
ratio of this measurement by many you
know factors of 10 or 100 000 by using
these entangled photons applications of
this might be what
well i mean um long-distance imaging
i mean a long-distance detection of
things you know uh uh places with names
like darpa
and are interested in that
what else what other kinds of things can
you do with this sort of precision
um actually you can use it actually for
microscopy so it and it would be quite
useful for medical imaging in the sense
that um optical medical imaging is hard
because you know my skin is opaque right
so people do use optical imaging but you
have to be worried about if you put in
too much laser light then you'll damage
the tissue
if you can enhance the signal-to-noise
ratio by a hundred thousand then you can
use you know only point zero one percent
of the number of photons to do the same
kind of detection so you could do
uh less invasive optical imaging
that's the kind of thing that that i
mean i don't know what do you think what
should we do with that
well i mean
it's open to anybody
you've got this well-funded institute
and it's it's uh sort of doing quantum
computing but it's doing quantum other
stuff say more about this range of other
stuff that you see coming well actually
this you know this kind of um uh look i
said before everything is quantum
mechanical but some things are more
quantum mechanical than others if you
look at things like sensing and
communication or making atomic clocks
right so the world's most accurate clock
in fact the world's most accurate
measurement device is dave weinland's
quantum logic atomic clock at the
national institute of standards and
technology nist in boulder and it
operates by using entanglement between
between electron spins and between
electronic states the states of atoms it
exchanges it back and forth and so it
can build an atomic clock that you know
that would lose a tiny fraction of a
second in the age of the universe it's
by you know it was when they built it it
was by it was it was again 100 000 times
more precise and accurate than the
previous atomic clocks and this is
actually just using these funky quantum
effects like entanglement and that kind
of stuff makes gps work better makes
everything work better you have that
extra level of capability yeah well i
mean actually it's so accurate in fact
it's it's you know atomic clocks are
extremely important for things like gps
you couldn't have gps without atomic
clocks because you need to measure the
timing of signals that are going from
satellites to you to within a billionth
of a second a billionth of a second as
light travels about that distance in a
billionth of a second a third of a meter
and um and so to measure your distance
to this kind of accuracy you need to
have clocks that can measure out time to
a billionth of a second and those are
atomic clocks
now these these uh these optical
frequency atomic clocks as quantum logic
atomic clocks measures out time to
within an accuracy of a femtosecond so a
billionth of a second is 10 to the minus
ninth second now these are 10 to the
minus 15 seconds so they're a million
times more accurate
so that you could actually measure you
know your distance to within a micron
or something like that a millionth of a
meter um actually they're so accurate
that it's kind of a problem because they
they can detect one of the most faintest
faintest signals of general relativity
is the gravitational redshift which says
that if it clocks in a gravitational
field it will slow down and so if they
raise the clock up by this much it will
detect the fact that the gravitational
field of the earth is very slightly less
strong at this level than it is at that
level
i mean maybe it's a little too precise
it's not for everybody
that's the holy [ __ ] cackling
[Laughter]
i mean it wasn't in the original whole
earth catalog but then the new version
you know
a couple years ago you did a book i
think it was called programming the
universe yeah which
suggested that the universe is a quantum
computer in a sense
um
you still hold to that
yeah i mean i actually don't i don't
suggest it i just simply declare it i
mean
it's
i mean it's it's it's demonstrably true
look the the the here's here's here's
the evidence i mean this is really just
a technical question i mean
either the system is capable of
universal computation or it's not
okay so universal computation has a
technical definition it means it can do
whatever a digital computer can do or a
turing machine with uh potentially
infinitely extensible memory okay so
it's a technical definition now the laws
of physics are quantum mechanical and
they're capable of computation i mean i
have a computer for god's sake you know
it's computing actually that's your
computer i'll take it with me when i go
by the way
yeah i mean so they support universal
computation the laws of physics support
universal computation and they're doing
it in a quantum mechanical way because
quantum mechanics is what guarantees the
stability of atoms you know the
existence of elementary particles the
fact that we have molecules undergo
chemical reactions it's all quantum
mechanical so the universe is quantum
mechanical and it's performing universal
computation it's performing computation
in a quantum mechanical fashion i rest
my case i mean i don't really see why
it's an argument
[Laughter]
so will
quantum computers help us grok the
universe
that's croc with a queue okay
please
or maybe
maybe maybe maybe
i'm sorry i'm sorry stewart gracu right
we gracu
groq the universe yeah
yeah i mean actually so so i mean why am
i out there building quantum computers
uh you know you know but i don't know i
it's a job but it's a nasty dirty job
somebody's got to do it you know it's
quantum mechanics so down there in the
pits you know you are in the
department yeah we have quantum
mechanics that's right you know if you
your quad are broke we fix them and we
charge a lot of money too by the way
no i mean actually my interest in this
um i i got interested not because i was
interested in factoring large number or
like striking fear in the heart of
agencies with three letters and their
names that's a dangerous thing to do
don't do it um uh but it's actually
because i mean i started doing this
before they had shor's algorithm this
and because i was interested in
how information is out there in the
universe and how quantum mechanical
systems are actually processing
information i mean i think this gives us
real powerful insights into how the
universe is put together i mean back in
the the enlightenment you know in the
1600s one of the great inspirations for
the enlightenment was galileo
discovering the basis for the pendulum
clock i was just in pisa a few weeks ago
i saw the original clock where the it's
actually the lamp in the cathedral and
pisa which when it was going back and
forth galileo realized that the the
period didn't change very even as the
amplitude gets smaller the period
remained the same he said ah you could
make a clock out of that
and then he did so he designed a
pendulum clock and it was such a
remarkable thing and it had such a
transformative effect on society because
you know
the notion that you could actually take
out time on the level of seconds rather
than figuring out time passing on the
level of hours um
was actually quite amazing so that's a
case where precision changes everything
increase and precision changes
everything it changes a great deal and
also a bit it has such a powerful effect
on people's minds they said oh let's
think of the world as if it were
clockwork and that insight was one of
the insights that that when newton came
along and said let us think of the world
as if it were a machine mechanistic and
we know how machines behave they obey
these with these regular laws f equals m
a you know galileo's law for motion for
gravitational motion let's think of the
universe's machine and see what comes
out and what came out was all of physics
that was a very powerful even if it's
just a metaphor it's a very powerful
metaphor
so now we actually have in the 20th
century 21st century that was the 20th
century when i started you know
then we have another machine which is a
computer which is a powerful way of
what's understanding what's going on but
to understand what's really going on we
know that the world is quantum
mechanical so if we want to understand
things in terms of information
processing is most fundamental level we
have to think of quantum information
processing we have to think of quantum
computation so i actually regard these
quantum computers as in fact
as ways as devices that help us to
understand what's going on the most
fundamental level and to give an example
i mean about starting about you know 20
years ago i started saying hey let's
look at this problem of quantum gravity
in terms of quantum computation
quantum gravity is famously something
nobody understands i was doing stephen
hawking has you know figured out the
only thing we really know which is that
black holes use some funky quantum
effect based on entanglement to actually
radiate that's about the only thing we
know about quantum gravity okay no
unless you're a string theorist in which
case you know everything about quantum
gravity but but you're not telling right
and experiments aren't doing much yeah
yeah but the thing is now it's become
clear over the last few years i mean and
people started thinking about this a
while ago as i mentioned that if you
think about uh quantum gravity in terms
of entanglement and in terms of quantum
information processing you can
understand things about how black holes
evaporate so my colleagues and i have
done experiments to look at what's
called black hole scrambling to look at
what happens to quantum information that
falls into black holes and how it could
come out so you know you could have a
little quantum computer which
effectively is a black hole in a lab
which is good because when you try to
make a real black hole
yeah they're workplace safety people
they're just all over you like
little minds you know
[Laughter]
what's wrong with having a black hole in
the lab
i can think of a few things yeah anyway
quantum computer that simulates a black
hole that's probably as close as
simulating is better there yeah so your
last book uh we had a declaration about
the universe uh do you have a next book
in you
yeah i've actually in fact i've i've
just uh uh uh again for the same reasons
i wrote the first book which is need of
money um
no that's not entirely true right
it's a similar thing i mean actually i
wrote the first book because in fact i i
do think this is a thinking about the
universe in terms of how it computes and
how it computes at a quantum mechanical
level really
gives a lot of insight into why the
universe is here and what's going on
so my next book is uh um about it was
inspired by finance but more kind of the
losing money side during the financial
crisis i don't know about people out
there but i watched my already meager
life savings
and it was very frustrating for me and
for everybody there was no haven even
for the very wealthy
and i said what can i do about this
there's nothing and i said well you know
maybe if i made a theory about this i'd
feel better
if i could understand it even if there's
nothing i can do so i was working
actually on these problems of about
black hole formation and stellar
collapse and origins of the universe
and i realized that in these
gravitational systems
there's a you know you have this funny
phenomenon you have positive energy and
matter and energy and then you have
negative energy and gravitation these
cancel each other out so the energy of
the universe is zero wait a minute how
come gravity is negative and these other
things are positive where does that come
from it's cause gravity sucks
[Laughter]
when you have attractive force it has
negative energy not in the kind of sense
like whoa your negative energy is really
turning me off yeah yeah
yeah
bringing us down not in that sense
but just like you measure energy and
it's negative okay so it's negative and
then newton this is a newton i mean it's
like
newtonian gravity the attractive energy
of the gravitational field is negative
negative kinetic energy of matter and
stars is positive okay and even in
newtonian gravity the energy of the
universe is exactly zero okay and um you
know the negative energy counter
balances in the gravitational
counteracts is positive energy and
matter okay now this feature of of
having this counterbalance of positive
negative energy when you combine it with
information processing you get something
really cool which is actually
responsible for everything we see around
us
it means that at the big bang when
everything was just all the same
temperature you'd think gosh how boring
everything's all at the same temperature
all the billions of degrees which is
actually not boring it's too exciting
but
then you know under ordinary
circumstances everything's at the same
temperature is going to remain at the
same temperature forever and it would be
really dull
but that's not what happened
you know what happened is it as the
universe cooled down all of a sudden
things started clumping you know the
seeds for galaxies started forming seeds
for of course for swirling clouds of
matter that would form stars in the
earth and so where did that lack of
uniformity come from well it's because
in these systems if you look at them in
terms of information processing
when you have this positive and negative
energy there's a fundamental instability
which is kind of homogeneity is not
stable some kind of granularity will
form yeah there's a natural tendency for
things to self-organize
and this is great for the universe i
mean it makes the universe a much nicer
place like you know there's all these
nice restaurants in san francisco
[Laughter]
all this variation and variety
chefs thinking about what they can do
over here or over there you know there's
all this kind of you know this
interesting complexity and computation
that's going on the universe comes from
this fundamental instability
now the problem is this instability goes
the other way around so if you look at
black hole formation what happens is
things get so dense that the negative
energy of gravitation overwhelms the
positive energy of the matter and
there's this huge sucking sound problem
and a gigantic explosion because there's
a it makes a supernova as the star
collapses
anyway during the financial collapse i
said you know you watch these big
investment banks like tottering around
overwhelmed by their negative energy of
their debts and some of them imploded
forming like supernovas of like failed
careers and junk bonds and things like
that i said you know this is kind of
similar
and then if you look at it more closely
you actually find that you know you just
do a theory of things that have positive
negative stuff be it energy
or money you know positive energy and
assets negative energy and debt and you
look at how they process information
they're intrinsically unstable which is
great for the universe in the case of
stellar formation is great if your
lehman brothers on the way up it was
great you know you were leveraged at 32
1 but what the heck the money keeps
flowing in but the problem is that these
systems are also you know it's one of
these what goes up can come down kinds
of things and when it does come down
it's bad right so it has this
fundamental creative force in this
instability for making the universe for
you know acquiring assets but then also
it's a destructive force you can also
get overwhelmed by the negative energy
and then
huge sucking sound anyway the whole
reason for this is to write a paper
called the black hole of finance right i
mean that's the only reason to do this
is that is that the title of the book no
no no no because actually the book is
it's that's really though of course it's
largely about this for fun it's also
about
the origins of life because
um we don't understand anything about
the origins of life really i mean as i
mentioned before we know much less about
the origins of life than we know about
the origins of the universe that's an
astonishing thing to say you know i mean
it's true it's true yeah it is true i
mean but it's an astonishing thing to be
true i know it's weird isn't it
but you're going to fix it no no no no
no no
no i mean it's very we don't i i don't
think we are going for the reasons you
were describing before right that life
is very complicated right now and it's
been very complex for for for billions
of years okay
and by improvising and putting together
all these different structures it's
covered its tracks extremely well
i think it's very unlikely that we're
going to look at living systems now and
be able to tease out what these pro
prebiotic mechanisms were the chemical
reactions that got together
started computing started self
reproducing that's going to be very
tough it's very conservative once it
sort of invents dna
uh
that's it it doesn't
start doing triple strands it just you
know really really sticks with stuff and
the basics of metabolism seem to be
really really really basic and
everything living has it yeah but
getting to that point you know getting
to the point where you have cells with
dna you know that's reproducing with
these mechanisms i mean you look at all
these incredibly intricate mechanisms
that go into reproduction of dna where
the heck did that come from okay people
just don't know that so what what have
you got on that what are you looking at
to
discern what's there
look i don't have a theory i think as i
was saying i think theories about the
origins of life are are suspect but i do
have a story okay
i mean let's end this story of life
well so i mean we have these chemical
reactions you know we have chemicals are
recombining to form other molecules we
combine to form other molecules you know
there's this natural tendency for
molecules to form in the first place
from this kind of what i call this
information edge when one part of the
system gets an edge on the other it
starts sequestering information and free
energy that's why molecules form in the
first place and once they start
interacting with each other you know you
have molecule a interacts with molecule
b to form molecule c
so we have a situation where c is only
produced if a is there and b is there
well that's an and gate right
if a and b are there then you get c if
only a is there or only b is there or if
neither is there you don't get c so you
get c only if a and b
and then you can have other operations
where if either a is there or if b is
there then it will produce c this sounds
like basic computation so far yeah so
the basic
equations that govern chemical reactions
and equations that cover things like
logic gates
are one in the same and that's this is
of course why the metabolism of a cell
works in the first place right you know
once a molecule comes in from the
outside then it gets into the membrane
of the cell let's say it gets through
the membrane inside the cell and then
this molecular this reaction start
taking place let's say if this molecule
is present then we start up this
mechanism to start to you know take it
apart and digest it and then we need to
bring in these other things but these
are simple kind of logical operations
that say you can encode them in this
metabolism they come because the
chemical reactions and logical
operations are basically the same
so so my goal in the in the the
this the story is that because we have
these chemicals they're interacting and
they're spontaneously computing
that they can actually start coming up
with more and more complicated ways of
responding to what's going on in the
same way that we can have computer
programs that come up with more
complicated ways and that adapt to the
kinds of information that's coming in
i mean but that's what is it that
fundamentally welcomes complexity
why would it tend in the direction of
greater complexity
welcome complexity speak for yourself my
man
some of us welcome
simplicity a plus b equals c and then
pretty soon you run out of the alphabet
because there's so many different things
doing that and then so many different
things doing that in the billions of
years it gets more and more and more
complicated and you can't reverse
engineer it because it was never
engineered in the first place so uh you
know what are we saying why is that this
is sort of a kevin kelly question you
know what is that trend that wants more
complexity
yeah well maybe we should ask kevin
because i don't know the answer but
yeah um well i don't know but i mean
there there are tantalizing hints about
this right so so we do know that if you
take these kinds of logical operations
as boole showed you know
170 years ago you can build up any
arbitrarily complicated transformations
of information out of you know and or
not and copy operations
we also know that very simple sets of
chemical reactions when put together can
build up sequences of and or non-copy
operations so
and then you know it could be and again
now there's a storytelling time here but
um you know so suppose they're
performing some simple set of operations
and then you have stimuli from the
environment now what you need is
something that says okay the ones that
are better at maintaining themselves
against stimuli in the environment those
are the ones that actually keep on going
right the ones that just dissipate into
nothingness upon the stimuli in the
environment
those aren't around any longer
now you have adaptation and adaptation
in a system that's capable of generating
greater complexity
i mean it sounds sounds nice
i mean you haven't fallen asleep yet
though a good bedtime story is a good
story too
well yeah
if math and physics and
astrophysics and the understanding of
life
all converge
which is what we're talking about here
this is one bodacious renaissance we're
in the thick
that would be a true renaissance i mean
i'm still waiting for the true the
second renaissance to come around i
think apps alone are not going to cut it
but uh
but i think human beings you know maybe
empowered by apps
well thank you for bringing on the
renaissance thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
go
[Music]
you